안녕하세요 이번에 무서운 결과를
만들기도 하는 공동 투자에 대해서
이야기해 보겠습니다 공동 투자라고
하면 여러 사람들이 같이 투자하는
거를 이제 공동 투자라고 하고 주로
법인을 설립해서 투자를 합니다 그리고
한 사람이 모든 과정을 다 맡아서
진행하는 경우가 많기 때문에 처음
투자하시는 분들은 되게 솔깃한 제한이
합니다 뭐 적은 비용으로 투자도 할
수 있기 때문에 근데이 공동 투자가
하면서 문제점이 많이 발생되기도
하는데 공동 투자를 제한하는 사람들은
자칭 전문가 라고 불리는 사람들이
많습니다 강의를 모집해서 부동산
지식을 알려 준다라고 하지만 공동
투자를 제한하는 경우가 많은데이
사람들이 왜 공동 투자를 제한하면
강의료 만 아니라 컨설팅 비용이 되게
높거든요 그것뿐만 아니라 중간에
소개해 주면서 받는 수수료가 꽤
크거든요 예를 들어서 뭐 중개
업자한테 받을 수도 있고 은행한테
받을 수도 있고 아니면 건축 업자한테
받을 수 있고 이런 부수적인 수입이
강의료 다 더 높기 때문에 이런
강사분들 소위 이제 전 전문가라고
불리는 사람들이 이런 공동 투자의
유혹에 빠지기가 되게 쉽습니다 저희
같은 경우에도 이제 스터디 교육을
하고 있는데 공동투자를 같이 해
달라는 문의가 되게 많았어요 제가
하지 않은 이유가 있습니다 분명히
문제가 발생돼요 그리고 오래 가지
못합니다 심지어 뭐 잠적하는 경우도
많이 받고 형사 처벌을 받는 경우도
많이 받거든요 그런 부분이 있기
때문에 저는 공동투자를 권장하지
않습니다 최근에 PD 수첩에서
나왔는데 부동산 경매로 굉장히 유명한
운영 중이었는데 수강생을 모집해서
부동산 경매를 알려 준다는게 아니라
부동산 경매 카페에 들어가서 공동투자
물건을 올리는데 정말 5분 이내로
마감이 될 정도로이 공동 투자가
굉장히 잘됐습니다 공동 투자에 임했던
사람들이 총 7천 명이고 투자 금액만
약 3천억이 넘을 정도로 엄청 많은
사람들이 공동투자를 했습니다 여기
사례 중에 물치도 아는 인천의 무인도
섬이 나옵니다 정말 사람도 안 살고
선착장도 없는 그런 밝은 섬이
나오는데이 섬이 감정가에 한 70억
정도에 나왔는데 이거를 94억 원에
낙찰을 받습니다 대출은 43억이나
받았고 수강생들 103명을 모집해
가지고 약 100억이 넘는 금액을
투자해서 사람 한 명 없는 이런
무인도를 매입을 했습니다 근데이
무인도가 문제가 뭐냐면 일단은 개발
자체가 좀 쉽지 않은 그런 땅이었고
선착장이 없기 때문에이 선착장
설치하는 거만 추가 비용으로 약
100억이 넘게 들어갑니다 추가비
이용이 너무 많이 들어가서 개발조차
안 되고 있는 상황이었어요 19년도에
매입했는데 5년 동안 아무런 행위도
하지 않았습니다 43억이란 대출 금액
때문에 매월 이자가 2,500만 원씩
발생되고 있었고 원금도 못 빼고 계속
이자만 납부하고 추가 비용만 발생되는
진짜 말도 안 되는 그런 실패
사례입니다 자격도 물치도뿐만 아니라
개발이 안 되는 진짜 말도 안 되는
땅을 매입해 가지고 돈이 묶여서 빼질
못하는 그런 피해자분들이 많더라고요
심지어 현장도 도 안 가보거나 아니면
개발이 되는지 안 되는지도 검토를 안
해 보신 분들이 너무 많았습니다
그리고 또 문제인게 뭐냐면 법인을
설립해서 샀어요 여러분들이 아셔야
될게 만약에 공동 투자로 샀을 때
그냥 공동 명의로 내 명의가
들어갔으면 소유권 행사를 할 수
있습니다 근데 법인으로 매입하면 법인
대표자가 다 의사 결정을 하거든요
그래서 소유권 행사가 좀 어렵습니다
그리고 이제 법인으로 매입한다는 건
정말 끝까지 같이 배를 타고 가는
거예요 돈을 빼기도 되게 어렵고 근데
지금 이 사례 같은 경우에는 법인으로
매입했기 때문에 대표자 의사 결정에
따라서 모든게 다 이뤄졌습니다 그러다
보니까 법인 통장에 있는 돈을
마음대로 빼는 거예요 뭐 횡령을
하거나 대열을 해 주거나 이런 경우가
많아서 내 돈이 어디로 빠져
나가는지도 확인조차 어려웠습니다
그리고이 사람 문제가 뭐냐면 공동투자
식으로 제한을 했지만 동업 계약서를
썼어요 그러니까 나중에 이제
법률적으로 피해가는 것까지도 생각을
한 겁니다 지금 공동 투자자분들은
지금 돈이 묶긴 것뿐만 아니라 매월
이자도 나빠 하고 있고 법인 주주로
들어가 있어서 내 소유권 행사도
어렵고 피해자분들은 아무것도 못 하는
되게 답답한 상황이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 그리고 저도 공동 투자를 좀
해봤지만 이게 아무래도 쉽지
않더라고요 돈이 아무래도 섞이면 서로
의견도 좀 다르고 누구는 팔고 싶고
그리고 누구는 팔기 싫고 그리고
원하는 금액도 다 다르거든요 또 한
사례 얘기하자면 이분도 이제 유튜버
분이었는데 본인 블로그에 공투
실패했다는 내용을 게재를 했어요 실패
마이너스 수익 률이 거의 한 80%
이을 정도로 정말 공투 해서 많은
돈을 잃었다고 해서 올렸습니다 물론
그때 당시에 금리가 진짜 말도 안
되게 많이 올라서 뭐 그런 부분도
생각해 볼 수 있지만 다른 사람들의
돈을 모아서 공투 한다라는게 정말
어렵고 그리고 시기도 잘 만나야 되고
많은 사람들이 있을 경우에는 의사
결정이나 생각지도 못했던 변수가
발생될 수도 있기 때문에 공투 하실
때 신중하게 어 생각을 해 보셔야
됩니다 그런데도 불구하고 내가 공투
해야겠다 라고 하시면 일단은 최소한의
인원으로 하셔야 돼요 다섯 명 미만
아까 그 물치도 자격도 봤었던 뭐
100명이 넘는 그런 투자자가 아니라
두 세 명 정도가 딱 많습니다 다섯
명이 넘어가면 일단 의견이 다 달라요
중간에 팔고 싶은 사람도 있고 안
팔고 싶은 사람도 있고 금액을 높게
받고 싶은 사람도 있고 급매라고 좀
던지고 싶은 사람도 있고 다 의견이
다르기 때문에 여러분들이 만약에 진짜
공투 하신다고 하면 변호사한테 분쟁이
될 만한 상황들 있잖아요 이거를
문서화해 가지고 가능하면 문제가
발생되지 않게 세부적으로 써 놓는게
되게 중요합니다 예를 들어서 얼마가
됐을 때 매각을 한다 그리고 어느
정도 소유했을 때 매각을 한다 그리고
이게 공투 때 또 문제점이 뭐냐면 한
사람이 주도적으로 진행을 해야 돼요
근데 대부분은 다 공투 아는 사람들이
단독 명의가 아니다 보니까 다
남들한테 맡겨요 그래서 산으로 가는
경우가 되게 많거든요 공투 한다라고
하면 한 사람이 주도적으로 해야 되고
뭐 그에 대해서 비용이 발생되면 뭐
부담을 해야 되고 그래서 누가 주도
도적으로 진행을 해야 됩니다 제일
중요한 건 주주로 들어가면 큰일납니다
어 법인 주주로 가면 큰일 나고 내
이름이 등기사항 전무 증명서에
들어가야 돼요 내 투자금 대비해서 그
지분이 들어가야 됩니다 그래야
안전하고 내 소유권 행사를 할 수가
있어요 그리고 여러분들이 공투
가족끼리 해도 싸우거든요 친척끼리
해도 싸우고 친구랑 해도 싸웁니다
근데 처음 보는 사람이랑 어떻게 공투
합니까 그래서 여러분들 공투 할 때
반드시 변호사 자문을 통해서
세부적으로 정리해 가지고서 로 남겨
놓는게 되게 중요한 거 같아 더
나아가서는 공투 1던 사람이 예를
들어서 뭐 사망할 수도 있잖아요 그럼
이제 상속자들이 문제가 발생될 수도
있는데 그러면 정말 골치 아파집니다
그런 내용까지이 법률 계약서에 자문을
받아서 반드시 써 놓으시길 좀 권하고
좀 덧붙이자면 명의를 다 넣고 대출
받을 때 그냥 신탁사에 맡겨 놓으세요
신탁사에 맡겨 놓으면 대출 조건이 좀
더 좋아질 수도 있고 예상치 못했던
그런 가압류가 안 들어오거든요 이미
명의는 신탁사기 때문에 플랜을 좀
정해 놓는게 중요합니다 그리고 비용이
발생되나요 비용이 발생되면 공동
통장을 만드는게 아니라 따로 지분별로
입금하는게 제일 안전해요 아무래도
공동 통장이 있는 경우에는이 사람이
돈을 어다 쓸지 모르거든요 그렇기
때문에 비용이 발생되면 무조건
지분대로 위치한다고 보시면 되고
이렇게 각각 따로따로 관리를 해야지
이런 공동 투자에서 진짜 뭐 소중한
원금을 잃거나 문제가 발생되는 경우가
없기 때문에 내가 진짜 공투 해야
된다라고 하시면 어 반드시 소수로
그리고 법률 자문을 받아서 분자 쟁이
될 만한 내용들을 미리 사전에 써
놓는 거를 검토 드리고 그리고
무엇보다 법인 주주로 들어가면 정말
큰일납니다 내 이름이 등기사항 정부
증명서에 반드시 들어가게 해 놔야지
이런 공동 투자의 리스크를 최소한으로
줄일 수 있지 않을까 어 이렇게
생각을 합니다 처음 투자하시는 분들이
아무래도 되게 좀 어렵고 그리고 특히
빌딩 같은 경우에는 뭐 건축 행위를
한다라고 하면 워낙 리스크도 많고
챙겨야 될 것도 많기 때문에 이렇게
현혹돼서는 경우가 많거든요 정말
위험해지는 경우도 너무 많이 고 돈도
빼지도 못하고 내 의지와 상관없이 막
여기저기 돈 쓰고 이러는 경우를 너무
많이 봐서 어 저는 개인적으로 공투
안 하는 걸 권장을 하고 공투 할
거면 그냥 건물 안 사는게 맞습니다
부동산을 안 사는게 맞아요 그래서
오늘 제가 공투 대해서 좀 말씀드렸고
공투 뭐 주변에도 많이 봤고 저도
공투 해봤기 때문에 최소한에
여러분들이 이런 공투 대한 리스크를
좀 줄이기 위해서 제가 오늘 좀
설명을 드렸습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 빌딩은 역시 빌사남
k
[음악]